ce
la solidarité entre européens elle est
au coeur du projet européen et de la
déclaration schuman et bien nous devons
continuer à être solidaire en traitement
plus que jamais avec cette crise par
yannick solidaire dans le domaine de la
santé solidaire dans le domaine de
l'emploi solidaire dans le domaine
social
joyeux anniversaire alors agir en
responsabilité c'est et hier les pères
de l'europe qui ont choisi de s'unir
pour construire la paix
agir en citoyen responsable cependant le
confinement respecter les gestes
barrière mais le petit coup tenir nos
agriculteurs nos pêcheurs dans nos actes
d'achat de mela continuons à faire vivre
cette responsabilité individuelle et
collective pour répondre aux grands
enjeux de l'europe ceux d'un
développement plus ou table qui respecte
la nature et les hommes
pas d'anniversaire l'europe prendre son
destin en main c'est défendre
l'autonomie stratégique de l'union
européenne pour ne pas dépendre de
l'amérique ou de la chine
c'est défendre nos marchés publics pour
nos entreprises européennes notamment
dans le spatial dans la défense mais
dans d'autres domaines également
et puis c'est enfin relocaliser des
activités stratégiques au sein de
l'union européenne
la liberté c'est une valeur qui s'est
imposé au fil de la construction
européenne et de sécréter
liberté de circulation des personnes des
marchandises mais pas uniquement la
liberté elle est avant tout défendu par
l'état de droit qui garantit la bonne
santé des démocratie la liberté
d'expression voilà pourquoi
actuellement nous sommes autant
préoccupé par ce qui se passe en hongrie
parce que être européenne et être
européen aujourd'hui c'est être libre
joyeux anniversaire l'europe montrer
l'exemple au monde
l'union européenne est un espace
politique en devenir
chaque jour nous bâtissons une europe
plus unie souveraine démocratique
c'est dans une logique d'ouverture dans
un cadre international que nous
souhaitons être leader pour porter des
ambitions collectives à la hauteur des
défis de ce siècle
joyeux anniversaire l'europe
[Musique]